bio informatics for infectious diseases
is an online training program designed
for biologists clinicians students that
are interested in biology and immunology
who would like to learn about the use of
bioinformatics and big data for
infectious disease research diagnostics
as well as drug design and vaccine
development as we hear more and more
about infectious diseases in the news
for the first time we can learn about
recent outbreaks and even the current
coronavirus pandemic
by analyzing data that is made available
for the research community with
increasing speed and in increasing
volumes
for this ongoing coronavirus outbreak
detailed maps have reported cases
genomic information from viral strains
protein structures and other data is
being updated on a daily basis opening
the door for anyone to access and use
this information
we've designed this program to introduce
the data resources and tools that you
can use to apply bioinformatics to
publicly available data on infectious
diseases in this program we will
understand viral diversity and its role
in epidemic infectious diseases that key
pre-emerge including zou anodic
transmission transmission between humans
and the process of viral and bacterial
disease development will learn about
bioinformatics analysis approaches the
study viral genomes and understand the
relationships between viral strains
haplotypes finding the differences in
sequence data and seeing the
implications of drug and vaccine design
you'll gain hands-on experience by
analyzing curated datasets from public
domain collections guided by experts
with bioinformatics experience and
knowledge about biology we will see how
bioinformatics can help us understand so
anodic transmission viral replication
and adaptation to various tissues in our
body which have the potential to evade
and overcome our immune response
together we will understand how data
analysis tools can help detect viral
genomes and next-generation sequencing
data we will identify specific viral
strains and study haplotype diversity by
analyzing next-generation sequencing
data processing fast queue and fast stay
files we will then apply comparative
analysis to gain insights into specific
characteristics that are important for
vaccine design and then look into the
principles of antiviral drug design as
well as the development of resistance to
standard drugs including super viruses
that do not respond to standard
antivirals and super bacteria they did
not respond to antibiotics
program will provide several examples of
disease projects with curated data sets
as well as guided analysis sessions to
see how bioinformatics is used for
infectious disease research in each
example we'll use an epidemic outbreak
and study available data to understand
how we can analyze factors that
contribute to the rate of infection
outcomes and other symptoms linking them
to viral genomic data will also discuss
major publications that come out during
and after these epidemics to see how
volumes of available data and innovative
approaches to data analysis let the
major discoveries that resulted in
better understanding of the disease
additionally we'll talk about the
development of vaccines and Thai viral
drugs and enhance our understanding of
disease progression that's changing both
diagnostic and intervention strategies
in the hands-on sessions you'll learn
how to find download and then use the
data that's available freely on NCBI
this data requires effective use of
bioinformatics analysis methods to
process analyze and interpret
biologically meaningful patterns
well then learn about these analysis
approaches to study viral genomes and
then practice on curated data sets that
have been prepared annotated and tested
by our team of experts
you'll have the opportunity to use the
intuitive T bio info platform where such
analysis can be performed easily for
large numbers of full genomes or even
NGS data directly from patients for
example in the course we will teach you
about the phylogenetic relationships
between different vowel strains by
performing a similar analysis on our own
this will be done in order to help you
understand how we can both visualize and
study this kind of data in a meaningful
and practical way by practicing analysis
on prepared datasets you'll begin to
understand the meaning of each step and
will be able to design an analysis of
your own you'll also be able to gain a
biologically interpretable result and
then visualize those as well as share
them with others will also review
several tools that are developed in
order to navigate large datasets and
then connect the various aspects of
sequence structure and metadata into a
single experience we will map mutations
that occur on the three-dimensional
structures of viral proteins which can
be studied separately or in complexes as
they are found during viral replication
inside the cell genomic data analysis
can be utilized to see the changes
between viral strains and different
significance levels of detected changes
due to the 3d position on protein
structures you will find that multiple
sequence alignment can be a powerful
tool to understand viral adaptations
that occur between animals and humans
additionally you'll study the
relationship between viral and host
proteins such as the trimeric SARS
coronavirus surface spike glycoprotein
this protein binds the cellular receptor
called angiotensin converting enzyme to
or a stew for short and mediates the
fusion of the viral surface membranes
through a pre and post fusion
conformational transition this type of
structural data is also important for
antiviral drug design such as NSP one
host transition inhibitor this protein
facilitates efficient viral gene
expression in infected cells as well as
the evasion from host immune responses
we will also discuss the relationships
between conserved regions and viral
protein
the structure of small molecule binding
sites and the efficacy of antiviral drug
design for diverse viral populations or
haplotypes typically present in a given
outbreak we welcome you to join the
program we invite students biologists
and clinicians to see the value as well
as the opportunity of big data to both
understand and study infectious diseases
and their agents which are viruses and
bacteria the program will start on May
4th 2020 we welcome you to register
early to benefit from discounts and
ensure availability